deputy prime minister is with us mr rob
good morning so we want to see thanks
for joining us uh let's start with the
stats should we give us an update on the
number of people uh who are in hospital
with omicron i don't know the precise
figures but we do know um that we've had
the first deaths there has been an
increase
and above all we're concerned about the
rate of transmission
the the positive side that we do believe
and again the information on omicron is
is still sketchy but if people get their
third jab they're over 70 percent
protected and so we've currently got
over 40 percent of adults with their
booster with their third jab the big
push is now by the end of the year to
get people that booster that is the
surest way we protect ourselves while we
find out a bit more about the real
impact of omicron you said death's
plural
how many i i'm not sure of the uh the
prime minister told us one yesterday
that's what that was my understand
that's the latest figures i know that
there have been so it's not plural it's
one again all i can tell you is the
latest uh that i've seen uh in terms of
plural i was referring to uh we now know
we've got a significant number in
hospital okay how many are on
ventilators i don't know uh the latest
facts i think and do we know the person
that died
did they die with omicron or because of
it
i think it's uh often very difficult to
say uh because a lot of people have uh
combined conditions if you like
particularly if they're they're old so i
don't know the answers and the truth is
okay just to be very honest we don't
know the full severity what we do know
is that the rate of transmission is so
rapid that even if the severity is
relatively low compared to other
variants that we've seen just because of
the numbers we need to take action now
which is why what the government is
doing today i believe is a targeted
proportionate approach as we find out
more come on to that i just wanted the
data check to start with which is very
helpful for our viewers you said a
significant number in hospital how many
well the last i saw was uh in the low
hundreds i think 250 the last time i
looked but of course the data is being
updated all the 250 out of 200 000
people who contracted it yesterday still
a very small number the problem is the
rate at which uh it is transmitting um
and if that continues we'll see those
numbers uh increase uh very dramatically
okay and then we know a proportion of
those hospitalized um will have a uh
possibly die or have a very serious uh
uh suffering of of the omri conversation
as a result of that you want people to
get jabbed as quickly as possible how
many people were jobs yesterday
i don't know yesterday but i know we're
up to 41
who have been uh triple jabbed on
saturday we got half a million uh get
their booster so that's why we want
everyone by the end of this month so by
the end of the year over 18 to be
offered that chance to get a booster and
again the the
missed the sketchiness of what we have
deciphered about omicron uh we know that
you're over 70 likely to be protected if
you from from it if you get that third
boost okay good job so you want a
million people a day to be jabbed
including on christmas day um half a
million or so uh yesterday i believe if
those are the figures that we're
normally looking at people waiting for
five hours in the cold what are they
going to wait 10 hours well no the look
i appreciate as we've ramped up uh this
campaign and people have come forward
which is good we want them to come
forward we know that there's been um a
challenge particularly getting the
online booking it's the same for lateral
flow tests we're dealing with that we're
making sure that we've got the capacity
the walk-in centers bear in mind that uh
at least up until wednesday this
wednesday the offer had been to those 30
year old or above but from wednesday if
you're 18 year olds or 18 year old or
above you can book online the walk-in
centers are there
we've deployed
various teams of military personnel yeah
to really ramp this up i appreciate that
with all these things as you introduced
in that pace there will be some teething
issues but we are uh ramping this up at
pace and it's good news yes
is the british public are ready
absolutely and you weren't
well look this is a rapid reaction to a
variant of over which we are gleaning
more information every day but we are
going to be ready we've ramped up the
plans the military involved the jabs
army the volunteers
supporting the nhs staff and we've got
the centres and we're boosting the
capacity to deal with um the volume of
people but as i said the the the shift
is being from wednesday the ability to
book if you're over 18 not just over 30.
why did you not do that earlier that
we're responding to this as swiftly as
we can in real time it's a a challenging
logistical operation
but we got the capacity to do this and
as i said we're straining every sinew
from the military to the volunteers to
the nhs staff to do this
given that will everybody who wants one
be able to get a job by the 31st of
december well look we everywhere yes or
no question well
well it is i mean you're telling me how
fabulous that all this work is
the offer will be yours so everybody who
wants a job will be able to have one
we're doing everything to get as many
people as we possibly can uh jabbed and
of course we're starting from now i
think it's 41 who've had the booster uh
we've got that capacity we're ramping up
and we want to get as close to uh that
as possible but look the offer is what
the target is to get everyone over 18
offered
that booster but no guarantee
look we'll do everything we can we we're
straining everything you you know we've
got that capacity up but the good news
is we've got half a million people
per day getting that boost and every
time we hit that with a day that's uh
half the million people with 70
protection 70 plus from omicron that's
good news so one of the ways to get
people through quicker is to get rid of
the 15 minute observation uh time once
you've had your booster what are you
going to do about that well i think if
we did that and uh you can always look
at things like that you'd get people
concerned about um any potential side
effects which are only for a small
minority um i mean i remember sitting
there 50 minutes and being champing at
the bit to get get off but i think i
think the nhs do want to make sure we
just look after and keep an eye on
anyone that might have a side effect
even if it's a very few small number of
people
so there's no guarantee and i understand
what you're saying there's no guarantee
31st of december that everybody will
have had the job even those who want to
even those who that want to stand out in
the cold when then will we find
ourselves in a position where uh fully
vaxxed means three jobs
well
sorry i'm not sure i quite answered at
the moment you have to in order to have
a passport you have to have two jobs you
were saying no that you have to have
three jobs at what stage well i think
let's gauge how far we get we want to
make sure of course we've got the
everyone who wants to have that jab
the opportunity uh and so we haven't got
a definitive timeline and of course i'm
reading this morning that um it's
february is that not right uh i don't
think a decision has been made it's
certainly not been set out and of course
it's not just that a reasonable time
february well look obviously what we
want to do is get as many
people with the booster as possible and
that would make it i think
easier to introduce that but of course
even if you haven't had
the double jab or in due course the
booster you can still rely on the
lateral flow test which is why i think
some of these
concerns about this are overstated in my
view because i think if you're going
into a crowded place um i would
personally want to for my own safety but
also for those around want to make sure
that i either had a lateral flow test or
i was um
double and due course triple jabbed so
i've on my travel passport at the moment
i have because i've had the booster it's
got all three uh registered on there
that's not necessarily going to be the
case you won't necessarily need all
three to show that you have been fully
vaxxed well the main thing is yes well
at the moment the rules are double jab i
understand what the rules are for a
lateral flow test yeah and of course
it'll depend if we look ideally we'd get
everyone triple vaxxed and that would be
that is the best way um because of
course the lateral flow tests are a
pretty reliable but not 100 reliable the
best way is to get vaccinated for sure
how are you feeling about vaccine
passports
look i i think it's a difficult thing to
do i do understand the concerns people
have but i think it's necessary i think
people want to see us grappling with the
omicron there in a sensible targeted
proportional way you you talked about
people feeling uneasy i know in other
interviews i've done they've said the
same thing i think we want to provide
that reassurance and i think this is a
proportionate way of doing so okay the
reason i mention it is because tory
backbencher marcus fish he this is his
quote i don't know how my viewers will
feel about it i'm interested how you
will we live in a free society in this
country where people have the freedom to
do what they want with their own bodies
and freedom of association we are not a
papers please society this is not nazi
germany it's the thin end of an
authoritarian wedge
how do you feel about this government
being compared to nazi germany um i'm
afraid i don't accept that but i know
marcus very well and i know he's got a
strong passion and uh he feels very
strongly about it's offensive uh liberty
look if you want to invite me to
criticize people i want you to
my viewers this morning will say that is
offensive i don't especially those of uh
who are jewish and look i don't accept
it and i don't think it's right and i
don't think it's
a reasonable critique but i do
understand the concerns people have but
all i would say as i said before is you
you know
either
you can demonstrate that you've had
you've been double jabbed or that you've
taken an actual flow test i don't think
that is a particularly intrusive thing
to do in order that we can all protect
not just ourselves but those around us
in the limited number of crowded
destinations or venues that this applies
to we're talking about i think it's 500
uh indoor over 500 people indoor over 4
000 outdoors i mean this is just i think
a sensible precautionary public health
measure that will protect us all
at least 79 of marcus vicious colleagues
agree with him though perhaps not
phrasing it quite the same and they are
going to vote against uh the government
proposition
today how do you feel about um
labour having to prop you up again well
look i don't think it's going to be the
case that they will have to prop us up
but the fact of the matter lose the vote
well i'm not sure you're right well i've
done lots of these votes before and you
get these numbers banded around the
media and actually have a debate and one
of the things you do in debate is you
listen to the other side i do think
that's important listen respectfully to
the other side and i hope the government
will be listened to as well we'll make
our case and i'd be very surprised if
the number was as high as you described
but the bottom line is the business of
government is doing what's right for the
country uh and uh that's what we'll do
what if it is as high as that
i look you can ask i don't know about
hypothetical questions the reality is
the government must do what it sensibly
believes is right in the interest of the
country i believe these are
proportionate measures coupled with the
big surge in the effort to get people
boosted before christmas i think that's
the right approach yeah but given that
and if there is a rebellion perhaps not
as high as 80 perhaps 79 that will mean
that you will have to look very closely
at wider restrictions and those are just
not going to come down the pie can they
or are they i don't think i think we'll
i think we'll get these measures through
i think uh i think a large number you
will because people will support you
well and i think that the number one
focus is on the booster campaign uh
because it gives us you that extra
efficacy against the omicron variant and
of course it's the temporary thing uh
because we need to find out more we
still got
fairly relatively sketchy sense of how
dangerous omicron is i understand those
who say well there's no um you know that
we don't know the full impact i
understand that i think what we've got
to do as government is to take a
precautionary balanced approach to stop
the worst implications and precisely
because you you know in three weeks time
i'd be on this show and you'd be saying
to me why didn't you act more swiftly we
are acting more swiftly but we're doing
so in a proportionate way
um deputy prime minister are we looking
at any further restrictions we've got no
plans but the plan is for plan b coupled
with the vaccine uh booster uh surge in
making that available and helping people
no further restrictions in the pipeline
look the one thing we know about
look the the no there's a plan b um
who knows whether there'll be another
variant along the the line but we're
learning more about the virus uh every
day we've got this omicron variant which
has uh
created a different set of challenges
but we're getting to grips with that and
we've got plan b and we think it's the
right one so we won't be paying for a
good christmas then we won't be paying
for a good christmas we'll have a lovely
christmas but you'll bring new reels in
uh very early in the new year look i
think people can go into this christmas
enjoy it um we've got an opportunity to
spend time with loved ones in a way that
we didn't last year and at the same time
i do think it's right to encourage
people to get the booster um vaccine
absolutely and and we'll go no further
restrictions are in the pipeline
look we've got none planned given this
variant as a result of this variant
there's no further restrictions in the
pipeline the plans are the plan b with
the masks in the settings that i
described um uh encouraging people to
think about whether they need to go to
work if they if they can work from home
if they can and it's the right thing to
do and yes we've got to take these other
measures in relation to particularly
crowded places indoor outside that
coupled with the vaccine booster
campaign is where all our focus is okay
i just want to ask you uh about um the
european court of rights before i let
you go almost out of time bill doesn't
act the bill that you're talking about
doesn't actually affect citizens rights
to seek redress does it at the european
court of human rights so so what does it
actually do we'll do three things uh
first of all we've got a proud tradition
of freedom in this country we'll
strengthen the quintessentially british
rights like freedom of speech the
liberty that guards all of the others we
have seen that whittled away recently
for various reasons secondly we can
prevent some of the abuses of human
rights that people care about the
ability of people to scupper deportation
orders who have been convicted of
serious offences and thirdly one of the
things i think people see is the
goalposts shift on human rights and
expand incrementally that ought to be
subject to democratic oversight by
lawmakers like me accountable to your
viewers and those are three big things i
think we can achieve take forward our
tradition of freedom in this country i
need christmas parties planned at dining
street this year do you know none that
i'm invited to
doesn't mean there aren't anything it's
good to talk to you as always thank you
very much indeed for joining us thank
you